Joel nice to see you thank you you look
like DJ Jazzy Jeff you've got Thank You
a nice there ya know well this is this
is thank you this is my Star Trek set
but of course I got this at the Funko
pop store with your image on it because
I like to work out to it I like to put
this on for working out to know what I'm
trying to get away from you wanna help
you you do more reps because like you're
trying to look at that shallow chest and
yeah I see
I wouldn't say your chest is shallow and
I would say it's concave nice sorry I'm
sorry that this is I want people to know
that that I'm not disabuse evasive with
you I'm sorry pretty much this abusive
with me all the time
that's but if it's any consolation I'm
the same with my kids yes I've seen that
I've seen you're very verbally cruel you
look great by the way
your hair is very naturally wonderful
and a I'm jealous it's it's just a
flippy-floppy thing that's all over the
place and who cares anymore
who cares do I mean and you the makeup
looks great no makeup this is no makeup
this is a ring light and look if I got
closer I won't it's too frightening oh I
thought you were like doing a bit like a
kabuki thing no this is my actual skin
tone it is yes wow that's incredible how
did your people survive to this time I
mean how did you get most of them didn't
actually and they took one step outside
that that hut in Ireland and just burst
into flame no I'm probably built for
quarantine really shouldn't be outside
okay let's say if there was an
apocalypse and you and I for some reason
were somehow we wound up together were
separated from our families but we have
to be on the run but we're here in
Southern California and all we have like
is our clothes but we do not have
sunscreen what would we do I would be
dead in two hours we could only travel
at night
you do better than me I think you have a
little dark Irish in you I you would
smell what you thought was cooking pork
look over and you'd see a little
smoldering smudge with a little bit of
tuft of orange hair and then you would
taste it for the nutrients and then you
would run 60 miles and find shelter okay
so you're gonna be fine